what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with moon knight yes we are we
are covering i guess the conclusion of
volume one for moonlight so here's the
thing if you go online and you look up
moonlight volume one you're basically
gonna see six issues it's really more
three is like a story arc then you have
an interlude story and then you kind of
have a two-parter but the last three
issues are really an interlude so we
could probably cover those separate but
this is the important one because it
basically builds on on what we saw in
the first issue as you guys know in the
the first video that we did with regards
to the new moon night run that somehow
people were basically being controlled
right and they were seemingly being
turned into vampires which is kind of a
weird thing now there's two story arcs
going on at the same time here right the
first story arc is that there are
actually vampires that are out there now
by and large what we talked about in the
first video is that it really seems to
be the motivations and the mechanisms of
vlad dracula right building up the
vampire nation and the goal of dracula
seemingly in the wolverine comics uh
seemingly with the incredible hulk
comics is that the desire of dracula is
to essentially attain blood that would
grant vampires a healing factor so that
they can walk around in the daylight
like blade does and not have to worry
about being destroyed by the sun and so
while that's going on that little bit of
a vampire story actually kind of segues
into this and what you end up doing is
basically picking up with a guy who's
just kind of asking these older
individuals like why are you doing this
and then basically they all kind of
chime with the exact same statement
because i want to sport just for the
hell of it right so these aren't really
vampires per se but they're really more
just people who are being controlled now
at that point you switch over to the
midnight mission right and of course
that's the name of the first volume but
the midnight mission is essentially what
uh what mark specter has now right where
he's basically kind of like a heroes for
hire s guy where he protects people in
the area right in his neighborhood but
he basically does so at night so people
can just kind of show up there as they
need to ask for help and he'll respond
now as we know from the first video that
rhys is basically one of the the newly
turned vampires that he had rescued and
rhys is amazing
i love the character of rhys like when
mark spector asks her like how do your
parents feel about you like being a
vampire and like working here with me
and that kind of a thing i mean she's
like well they're as happy with my new
condition as they are with me working
for a guy who runs around in a white
hood so like that's kind of a funny
little reference
i kind of dig that but like rhys is kind
of like this no-nonsense woman right
like sure mark spector saved her and
there is loyalty there but it's also one
of those like i'm not your servant right
like if you want something do it
yourself so he basically has an
assistant that just doesn't really do
anything unless she wants to do it right
so an assistant who works on her own
terms but in the middle of all this
suddenly that guy who was seemingly
attacked shows up here right now again
that's the nature of the midnight
mission right like you're that crazy
freaky guy that everybody talks about
they say like if you need help come and
talk to you i need help right and then
of course reece chimes in and saying
that like she knows who this guy is that
this guy's name is soldier and he lives
in one of the tenements that basically
exists you know around the corner from
of course a tenement basically being a
building those guys who don't know a
tenement is a building like an apartment
building that only ever has one entrance
so like you guys have seen those
buildings where like you walk through a
main door and then you have to take like
stairs up to the top to the top
apartments or stairs down to the bottom
apartments or like there's some right in
front of you that's a tenement building
and so of course it's one of those
things where he kind of explains what's
going on when he asks them like you know
what what happened like you know like
was it an elderly person with like a
knife or a hammer or something like that
and he says it was a whole bunch of them
right like it was a whole bunch of
elderly people who basically attacked
him at the same time now it's one of
those things where jed mckay is also
kind of messing with us at the same time
right like this young guy was attacked
by a bunch of old people
but the thing here is that soldier
basically says that one of the elderly
people who attacked him was his mom more
so than that he just wasn't really keen
on attacking a bunch of old people and i
mean you know granted his life was in
danger but you're talking about a bunch
of old people we're like a good shot to
the head they'll basically be finished
with all their living like they are a a
portion of society where they can be
easily hurt right so it's not one of
those things where you just rush head
long into attacking old people and i
don't think many many people would be
okay with that right like a person just
beat up a bunch of old people like
there's no real way to turn that story
with a positive light but there's not
really any circumstance where you could
say yes i beat up 15 old people last
night but here's what happened and then
people would say oh okay i understand
there's no circumstance
well that's going to be acceptable and
so one of the things that happens here
and this is kind of a cool little thing
and i feel like this is going to be a
plot device going forward is that with
reese having helped soldier essentially
recover due to all the various injuries
he's sustaining and so on and so forth
while mark is tending to him she gets
blood on her hands and then she kind of
starts to succumb to the bloodlust right
the desire to consume blood she of
course runs right she's like no i don't
have anything to do with this and she
basically backs off and then just ends
up taking off but i feel like it's going
to be a bit of a plot point more so than
that because mark spector is essentially
harboring vampires here you guys have to
know it's only a matter of time before
blade shows up and i am excited to cover
that story right it's gonna be super
clickbait moon knight versus blade
that's gonna be a ridiculously clickbait
title for a video
i mean tell me you wouldn't watch that
if you if you post a comment telling me
no rob i would not watch a video where
moon knight fights blade i wouldn't
believe you not even for once i'd be
like you're lying like you are
absolutely gonna watch that video and
i'm excited to cover that story
but regardless as they basically kind of
make their way around and get back to
where the initial incident basically
takes place that what you have is a
janitor that works in this building
named holly and that what happens is
holly you know when he's when when the
soldier's like hey my bad man you know
we just need to step through here real
quick he says no problem sport now the
important thing here is that when mark
was talking to soldier that he talked
about how all the old people kept
referring to him as sport so seemingly
it tells us more or less what's going on
right and so mark spector kind of picks
up on that initially but once they get
in there and they kind of start looking
around for soldier's mom of course she
cannot necessarily be found soldiers
like i gotta get my gun when mark steps
out all these different old people start
attacking him and that's when you find
out holly is the one behind this right
there where mark breaks out his little
little battering stuff like this that
like you know it's kind of like okay
holly's the guy behind us now before you
dismiss this and you think it's dumb i
mean it kind of is but like there's this
ridiculously amazing moment that happens
here right so what you end up finding
out with holly is that he's not that
dissimilar from the purple man right
zebedee kilgrave emits pheromones and
that unless you have an incredibly
strong level of willpower or you have a
kind of telepathic protection that
blocks those those pheromones from being
able to intercept your neurons that you
will succumb to him and so what holly
had been doing is that because it's his
sweat that basically drives people to
essentially follow him that he'd have to
kind of like you know force you to
ingest his sweat which no one's running
around and licking the the bald head of
holly right what he actually ended up
doing was basically poisoning the water
supply in the building and he never
really considered it to be like a big
thing right he never really considered
himself as a person who had a huge level
of imagination and what he actually says
here is he did this at the request of
somebody else right somebody asked him
to basically came to him and said hey
you should do this well you should kind
of you know do this a little bit and get
the attention of moon knight and so
using older people to basically do his
bidding that where this initially
presents a circumstance where they're
brandishing like knives and stuff like
that the response of of moon knight is
actually here's here's the deal i'll
make with you what you're doing here is
small time stuff right controlling
elderly people and some tenement
building somewhere this is small stuff i
know people who can do things like this
on a much broader scale and i'm an
avenger right or at least i have been an
adventurer i've got ties to the
superhero community what you're doing
here is you're wreaking havoc in a
tenement building imagine what you could
do if you had me under your control you
kind of you say you have no real
imagination here what i think is you
just haven't really found a worthy
challenge yet and so this kind of goads
the ego of holly to a degree and so
mark's like here's what we'll do take
this little crescent ring and apply your
sweat to it and then i'll consume your
sweat which is weird but he's like i'll
consume your sweat and then you and me
right brain to brain we'll see who
really is the tougher of the two of us
now here's the funny thing about this
right that it's not one of these things
where mark's pulling a ruse where like
he's gonna like trick holly and punch
him in the face you know and then or
whatever that he actually is going
through with this the funny thing here
is mark says here's the thing holly
you've never seen anything like what's
in my head and i'm not talking about you
know some kind of mental illness i'm
sure something like disassociative
identity disorder is old hat for you
right you've dealt with people who have
multiple personalities and you dominated
all of them he says after all you're
used to sharing space in someone's head
he says let me show you something new
you who have touched any number of minds
how does it feel to touch the truly
alien the universe is composed almost
entirely of darkness holly it's the
default state an uncaring indifferent
nothing cold and impenetrable little
wonder then when early men looked up
from the terrifying darkness of night
beset by predators on all sides and
worse and then they saw light they
worshipped it as a god mine is the cold
fire of the moon mine is the tidal pull
on the salt blood beating through your
heart mine is the silver madness that
illuminates but does not warm and he
says come and worship it is amazing
right it's just see here's here's here's
the thing like if here's something to
know about moon knight right here's the
thing moon knight is one of those
characters where if he's written
decently you feel it right it's like
okay i mean whatever like it's a moon
comic when he's written well he's
phenomenal and it's one of those those
crazy cool things right because he says
my brain is moon silver lunatic cratered
with a god's fingerprints the deep
structures of my mind have been
irreversibly changed by communion with
an ultra-terrestrial intelligence this
is my poisoned ground this is my temple
but i take my weaknesses and turn them
to my advantage i take my scars and make
them my weapons and so in essence what
he does this is actually a really really
important moment here one of the big
questions you had to ask is like what's
going on with the other personalities
right if mark spector is the one who's
basically running the show here what's
going on with the personalities of like
steve grant and jake lockley like what
you find out is like following the run
of
jeff lemire remember whoever was it
wrote it that basically mark specter's
in total control of his personalities
and has seemingly locked them away and
that's what he does with holly he
basically takes the mind of holly right
like literally takes his mind and locks
it away imprisons it in his in in
literally in the mind of mark specter so
there's nothing likely can do that once
it's all said and done lockly's just in
a comatose state right he's literally a
body without a mind that's basically
what's going on and so imprisoning him
in his own mind is huge because it gives
us a few of a few understandings of
what's going on with mark one that mark
has total control of his faculties and
two the supernatural element of moon
knight is not lost it's not gone it's
still very much a part of him and that's
one of those things that we had to
contend with because we didn't really
know if that was the case that during
the avengers story arc by jason aaron
when konshu was basically defeated and
locked away and mark had walked away
quote unquote from being a direct fist
of konchu and started doing his own
thing were his powers cut off with it
was he basically just a guy who's
entirely mortal with no supernatural
connections whatsoever just running
around in the night and like fighting
people or does he still have abilities
and the answer to that is he still has
powers this is huge and it's really
really cool because once the day's saved
and everything is essentially over that
you end up finding out that he's being
watched by badeer now switching over to
that is a cool thing because as mark's
talking to his therapist he literally
tells her like i have an enemy right
there is somebody out there and it's one
of those things where the conversations
between mark and his therapist are as
much existential as they are direct
right that mark without having konshu
telling him where to go and what to do
to a degree is almost kind of flying by
the seat of his pants right that the
bottom sort of fell out but at the same
time there's a level of freedom that he
hadn't really experienced before that
he's able to go forward as basically the
fist of konchu seemingly with all his
powers intact but he's not beholden to
the whimsical desires of a moon god
right that he's basically doing his own
thing but the biggest concern that he
has is that this enemy that exists out
there he's almost kind of afraid it's
himself now he doesn't give a definitive
answer as to why but we could speculate
that perhaps he's developing a new
personality that this new personality
takes over and then starts instructing
people to do things and basically mark
spectre creates his own enemies in order
to serve his purpose of being the fist
of konshu it's entirely possible that's
the case that kind of thing has happened
in the past a more direct answer here is
that the sins of his own past are
basically catching up to him and in fact
in his conversation with badeer that
seemed to be the case right that bader
basically illustrated that he or at
least made this declaration that he was
a fist of konchu he was kind of the the
other hand and that he's coming after
mark and so because of this you end up
finding out that essentially one of the
other people that mark had taken in one
of the other vampires that he had
basically been been kind of watching out
for that they were coming after him
right that they were basically trying to
take out these different people that
somebody had basically tried to kill ted
and of course what i wouldn't say that
seemingly recent ted are like the best
friends that like they share a kind of
common bond right so they're very
similar to like the midnight suns in
that way i mean they're not best buds
right they're not bffs they don't go and
do stuff all the time or at least that
doesn't seem to be the case but
regardless ted is somebody that was
being chased after by someone and that
when reece pulls out the crescent moon
of moon knight she doesn't really blame
him right i mean she knows what he was
doing at the time she knows that he was
tracking down leads but the question is
who's doing this right like who's coming
after these things and so mark pulls it
together pretty quickly that is
basically the deer he doesn't really
dump that information to reese but he's
like i you know more or less he knows
what's going on and so as a result he
actually ends up kind of making his way
through rooftops and so on and really
just trying to draw the attention of
veneer which happens and a fight breaks
out between the two of them now this is
the cool thing about what jed mckay's
doing here that when moon knight has
gotten into fights with people in the
past they're usually pretty
straightforward they're not overly
complex and that moon knight usually
gets the upper hand pretty fast in this
instance badir gets the upper hand of
him right like he literally he he
overpowers moon knight so incredibly
quickly and in fact when moonat asks him
like who are you supposed to be the
response of vadir is i'm the hunter's
moon right on the other fist of konshu
and it's this really really cool concept
because as they're talking mark's like
no i told you i was the fist of kanchu
and that's it but the response of vader
says but every man has two fists mark
surely you weren't so arrogant or stupid
as to believe that our god only has one
hand right surely you had to know that
if you are a fist of khanshu there had
to be a second one out there somewhere
and so it's cool because the response of
a deer is not necessarily to destroy
mark right it's not to like kill him and
then wipe him out then instead they're
supposed to operate kind of at the same
time right like the left hand knows what
the right hand is doing but they're
supposed to complement each other that
as a fist of conscious there are things
that mark is supposed to be doing more
so than that one of the things video
says is like you've taken vampires in
right we as the fists of khanshu are
here to basically protect those who walk
during the night and to destroy those
who prowl during the night what do
vampires do mark vampires feed in the
night you've literally taken in the
sworn enemy of concho or at least one of
them right like they are predators they
are the antithesis of kanchu they
literally exist to be the opposite of us
and then you've taken them in right you
are protecting some of them that's not
what you're supposed to be doing and so
one of the things that goes on is that
mark looks at the situation with holly
and then asks leipadir why did you send
him here he was like what are you
talking about i had nothing to do with
that and so literally like there's
another force at play here right there's
something else going on and so as they
kind of continue to fight one of the
things that happens is that that media
basically says like i don't understand
you right like i don't like what's wrong
with you i'm not referencing your your
softness for vampires or anything like
that it's the way you move mark spector
the way you fought you are a fist of
conscience but there's nothing of beauty
in the way that you fight right you
fight with a kind of recklessness right
you fight with no real sophistication
there's no real fluidity in your
movements you are basically just kind of
punching and hammering away what's going
on he says like you fight like an animal
right you should move with skill and
prowess of every fist to ever serve
konshu as i do did you not receive the
gift of the chorus upon your ordination
were the memories of konshu's previous
fists not invested in your mind this is
huge because what this is jed mckay
doing is basically expanding everything
it's not dissimilar to what ed brubacher
and matt fraction did with the iron fist
one do you guys remember that for years
and years and years and years there was
just danny ran the iron fist right like
a person who left loon with the
ability to use the iron fist went back
to new york and was basically a street
level superhero who was also like ultra
rich but that during the ed brubaker and
matt fraction run you learned that danny
rand was just the more recent iron fist
before him there was like orson randall
and before orson randall there were a
host of other iron fists that the
tournament of the seven heavenly cities
and so on was a great big huge part of
this mythos that we never knew about
that's what it looks like is going on
here that what was supposed to happen
when mark spector became a fist of
conscie is that he would be bestowed all
the knowledge of all the different fists
that came before him but for whatever
reason that didn't seem to happen and
that even with mark himself he's like i
already had too many personalities in my
head right so it looks like jed mckay is
basically expanding on the moon knight
powers and repertoire and so on right
that moon knight himself that mark
specter will probably see an increase in
his powers and an expansion and what
he's capable of the longer the story
goes on and that's what's so cool is
because madeira's like you are far more
broken than i thought you were right
like your connection or whatever it is
that you were supposed to be you are not
a true fist you did not undergo the
process that fists of konshu undergo
when they become a servant of him
somewhere along the line you've been
broken and so the intention of vadir is
to basically fix him to get him back to
where he's supposed to be and so one of
the things he says is like your
connections to the people around you
that's what makes you weak and he says i
will make you fit for your duty after i
remove the distractions from your life
it will be easier for you after that and
basically goes after all the different
friends essentially of of mark spector
at the midnight mission and then like
once he busts in and immediately starts
going after all of them he basically
disarms them off with the intention of
basically beating them all to death and
then of course mark shows up and then
crushes this guy right he doesn't kill
him he absolutely crushes him now this
is an important thing that i hope you
guys are noticing here that in these
different moments right when mark was
dealing with holly that when mark is
dealing with with this guy right dealing
with uh with badir it's almost like he
becomes a different person right it's
almost like a different aspect of him
takes over he says like at the end of
the day you're just a doctor dancing in
borrowed shoes and he says that's why i
win and then when veneer says like you
are you're being an absolute fool the
response of mark is probably and more of
one still for letting you live tonight
but know this before you decide to come
after frightened children under my
protection again whomever or whatever
they might be you better have what it
takes to kill me for good because when i
come back and i always do i'll do you
like they did osiris they'll never find
all your pieces and he says so go fist
of kanchu drag yourself away from my
temple and avoid my attention in the
future lest i become even more
interesting that he basically seems to
have this kind of darker side that just
takes over him right even if it's not a
drastic shift in his personality it's
minimal it's small but it's like he
becomes a different person but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end let me know what you guys
think about jed mckay's uh moon knight
run so far i love it man it is
phenomenal it's some of the most
interesting writing that i've seen for
the character of moon knight in years
but thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace